maître robert bonsoir
d'abord comment vous avez réagi à ce
jugement
en fait vous pour vous dire la vérité
quand j'ai entendu des extraits de
jugement ce matin et j'ai constaté les
réactions ma première opinion ça a été
de me dire qu'on va encore dire que le
système de justice ne fonctionne pas ce
qui n'est pas exact à mon sens c'est sûr
qu'on parle toujours des décisions qui
sont troublantes pour l'opinion publique
plutôt que les décisions qui sont qui le
sont moins cette décision qui sont
favorables aux accusés en toute matière
fraîche la population alors en matière
d'agression sexuelle c'est sûr qu'avec
le coureur moi aussi c'est peut-être
plus marquants mais il reste je veux pas
me prononcer sur la justesse de la peine
mais il reste que bon c'est une décision
qui est bien sûr étonnante pour qu'ils
aient eu des réactions comme celle là
elle est étonnante avez vous
l'impression que c'est un cas à part que
c'est un cas isolé ou que finalement ça
peut représenter des coqs qui existent
mais dont on parle pas quand même dans
le système de justice
c'est ça en fait le cap l'absolution
qu'elle soit conditionnelle ou
inconditionnels étaient pas une mesure
exceptionnelle race est pas une
est ce que c'est juste nation de
l'absolution conditionnelle
la commission d'abord c'est une absence
de quasi judiciaire la personne est
trouvé coupable personne est condamnée
mais les caps août alors elle se
retrouve sans casier judiciaire
avec ou sans condition d'âge précis et
des conditions parce qu une probation de
trois ans qui est imposé
c'est sûr que ben j'ai dit que c'est une
aubaine qui est pas exceptionnel c'est
sûr que les gestes qui ont été posés
sont très graves pour une absolution
souvent en matière d'agression sexuelle
quand on a des absolutions savoir dans
des cas où il ya eu des touches et par
dessus les vêtements
très très bon je peux pas nécessairement
donner des exemples de gestes mais une
tape sur les fesses par exemple ça va
être un dossier pour lequel on pourrait
voir une peine d'absolution qu'ils
soient imposées dans ce que si ce sont
des gestes qui sont très graves et le
juge aurait insisté sur les facteurs
atténuants
il n'a pas trouvé beaucoup de facteurs
aggravants
les facs les critères pour imposer une
absolution c'est important de les
comprendre il faut que ce soit dans
l'intérêt véritable de l'accusé c'est
pour ça qu'on a parlé de voyage oui non
pour que ce soit dans l'intérêt
véritable de l'accusé est faux il faut
que ce ne soit pas contraire à l'intérêt
public ça ne pas être dans l'intérêt
public mais ça nous deux ça ne doit pas
être contraire à l'intérêt ce sont ces
sur les critères de l'absolu j'aimerais
revenir aux critères d'intérêt public
dans un instant mais vous avez parlé de
voyage à lorsque le juge jeudi c'était
que pour permettre à cet ingénieur de
pouvoir voyager il fallait pas avoir de
casier judiciaire parce que ça pourrait
l'en empêcher
est-ce que ça crée un système finalement
de deux poids deux mesures face à une
autre personne reconnue coupable mais
qui ont une profession moins
prestigieuses
c'est l'impression que ça donne dans ce
cas aussi parce que la personne en
question n'avait pas à voyager pour son
travail mais vous savez on peut décider
qu'une absolution va être approprié pour
un jeune qui a pas du tout qu'il n'y ait
pas d'une d'un milieu riche que pour une
profession libérale parce que par
exemple pour façon métiers de la
construction et doit se rendre dans un
pénitencier on peut penser à une
absolution pour un artiste en arts
visuels qui doivent voyager pour des
expositions alors dans ce cas ci ce qui
est particulier c'est que l'accusé
n'avait pas à voyager pour son travail
c'est pas en preuve qui devaient voyager
pour son travail mais habituellement
effectivement le besoin de voyager vos
rangs vont amener le juge à penser que
c'est peut-être dans l'intérêt véritable
d'avoir une absolution donc de ne pas
avoir de casier donc vous avez parlé de
l'intérêt personnel maintenant parlons
de l'intérêt public est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que dans ce cas si cette
peine-là sert l'intérêt public ou au
contraire ça vient ébranler la confiance
dans le système de justice dans les cas
d'agression sexuelle justement oui la
confiance du public dans le système de
justice ça fait partie des
considérations lorsque la cour doit
déterminer si c'est contraire à
l'intérêt public alors ici on n'a pas le
choix de constater laquelle le public r
confiance en l'administration de la
justice devant une décision comme celle
là on n'a pas le choix de constater ccc
ce qu'on voit depuis ce matin ya de bons
cd on sait que c'est déjà en appel on
sait que des jeunes pleins de conseils
de la main stratus les gens sont en
colère
alors c'est un critère qui est à
considérer évidemment tous les facteurs
de détermination de la peine tous les
principes de détermination de la peine
doivent pas considérer y compris
l'importance la dissuasion générale on
est en matière d'agression sexuelle on
est après le mouvement moi aussi vous
savez les mouvements sociaux font
évoluer le droit alors c'est sûr que le
droit de risque d'évoluer de changer
avec un mouvement comme celui qu'on
vient de vivre partout dans le monde
mais
sur la question de la confiance du
public en l'administration de la justice
c'est un des critères à considérer pour
décider si l'absolution serait contraire
à leur public mais comme vous le dites
c'est un cas qui va suivre son cours m
robert un gros merci qui merci d'avoir
démystifié look précisé c'est quoi ce
concept d' absolution conditionnelle
bonne soirée fait plaisir aussi au
revoir